je suis assez étonné en fait je pensais
que ce serait plus dur que ça on m'avait
dit voilà beaucoup de choses on m dit
que c'était assez dur beaucoup de côtes
donc voilà je suis parti avec un rythme
assz tranquille Alice Gastine fait
désormais partie de ces milliers
d'amateurs qui font la popularité des
courses sur route parisiennes loin
derrière les grands favoris kan et
éthiopiens dont zaoubalou vainqueur au
sprint en quelques 47 minutes notre
journaliste franchit la ligne de sa
première course avec beaucoup de fierté
ouis très fier non vraiment je me suis
vraiment dépassé pour moi parce que j'ai
couru toute seule je devais pas la faire
au départ et puis je me suis dit bon
allez on verra bien voilà j'étais pas là
pour faire un temps j'étais juste là
pour la finir et puis et puis me prouver
des choses on va dire et je suis
vraiment ou je suis vraiment heureuse
une classique comme parisversaill ce
n'est pas seulement bien courir le jour
J c'est le type de course que l'on
prépare minutieusement pour pouvoir
palier à tout coup de fatigue sur le
parcours c'est la première course longue
don je m'étais bien entraîné j'avais
suivi les conseils de de mon coach qui
se
reconnaîtra voilà une bonne alimentation
bien s'hydraté c'est vrai que je pensais
pas que tout ça tout ce qu' a autour en
fait l'hygiène de vie c'était aussi
important que ça juste avant de derir
avitaillement j'ai un petit coup de mou
et puis il y avait des il y avait toute
une troupe de marathoniens derrière moi
là qui sont mis à crier à chanter je me
suis dit bon allez je les suis et puis
ça va me remettre dedans puis après il y
avait des sucres ravitaillement et
c'était bon ils étaient près de 25000 au
départ 21200 sont allés au bout de ce
35e parisvaill et Alice Gastine a
respecté ses objectifs en franchissant
la ligne après 1
sa prochaine échéance est déjà dans
quelques jours la journaliste s'alignera
sur le 10 km de parcourir Montini
peut-être déjà piqué par le virus de la
course à pied